also erstmal wahnsinnig vielen riesen
dank für die tollen themenvorschläge der
jetzt vor allen dingen auf sap macht ich
bin total begeistert aber da gibt es
auch sachen von
verschwörungstheoretikern die mehr
thesen verkaufen wollen die einfach
komplett daneben sind und ich will jetzt
mal klartext sprechen was ich davon
halte also herzlich willkommen bei pixum
science fiction klartext
ja ihr habt vielleicht mitbekommen dass
ich da eigentlich eine ziemlich klare
einstellung zu habe was ist die
verschwörungstheorie was ist eine
theorie was ist eine hypothese
denn das ist ganz wichtig zu wissen und
was mir da an verschwörungstheorien
wirklich um die ohren fliegt das kennt
manchmal wirklich keine grenzen also
wenn jemand behauptet die erde sei flach
dann gibt es so viele beweise
ich meine nur warum gibt es keine flach
jupiter riana und so weiter und so fort
ihnen maskat letztlich nach dem club der
flach marsianer gefragt die gibt es
nicht weil alles andere um uns herum
sind kugeln und die erde eben auch warum
sollte es anders sein und klimawandel
genau das gleiche da geben und die
runden drei prozent die nur co2 von
menschen dazu gemacht werden aber das
leider jedes jahr
und deshalb haben wir fast 50 prozent
mehr co2 in der atmosphäre als vor der
industriellen revolution und so weiter
und so fort all diese theorie
diese verschwörungstheorien auf youtube
videos und das macht mich wirklich mal
wo einfach wirklich quatsch drin erzählt
wird das hängt mit lügen an und es wird
so getan als wäre das in irgendeiner
weise wissenschaftlich oder sonst was
die fakten werden durcheinander
gewirbelt und zusammen geknetet und ich
möchte euch eine kleine geschichte aus
meiner schule erzählen die mich dazu
gebracht hat alles mal in meinem kopf
hier oben in meinem gehirn das ist super
zusatzgerät was wir hier oben haben
alles einmal durch zu durchdenken bevor
ich jemand etwas glaube und das war im
geschichtsunterricht wir hatten wir
einen ganz tollen lehrer das war ironie
also er war nicht ganz toll sondern er
wollte uns erklären warum kein einziger
arbeiter im dritten reich die nsdap
gewählt hätte hintergrund war er war
mitglied der der deutschen
kommunistischen partei dkp und die
hatten offensichtlich weisung von ihrer
partei die schüler in den deutschen
schulen wenn sie die möglichkeit hatten
so zu indoktrinieren
das konnte natürlich nicht stimmen da
braucht man sich nur ein bisschen die
die die wahl zahlen die wahlanalysen
anzugucken und schon kann man drauf und
das was dieser mann behauptet stimmt ich
habe ja gemacht hat er hat sich unser
geschichtsbuch genommen hat in der
quelle dort
genommen hat gesagt da steht da drin und
dann hat er eine eigene quelle
rausgekramt hat gesagt guck mal da steht
das gegenteil drin also stimmt meine
quelle
und diese quelle nicht in diesem moment
haben wir als schulklasse angefangen zu
arbeiten wir haben selber recherchiert
wir haben selber unser zusatzgerät
eingeschaltet nicht vergessen und haben
herausgefunden ausdehnen und den
objektiven faktischen gründen kann das
nicht stimmen was ist weiter passiert es
gab einen elternabend und am schluss
musste dieser lehrer vor die schulklasse
treten und sich in aller form
entschuldigen
seitdem weiß ich erstens den unterschied
zwischen der verschwörungstheorie
zwischen einer theorie und einer
hypothese nur noch mal ihr habt
vielleicht das video von niedriger ist
eis nie auf dem kanal gesehen da können
das noch einmal nachhören
wieso eine wissenschaftliche theorie
funktioniert dann eine theorie in der
wissenschaft zum beispiel die
evolutionstheorie ist nicht nur bloß
eine theorie sondern sie ist bewiesen
anders die theorie der dunklen materie
und der dunklen energie
sie ist nicht bewiesen es gibt tausend
indizien es ist eine hypothese und dass
die sonne kalt ist die erde flach ist
und dem mond einer raumstation iss das
sind nicht nur keine theorien sondern
sind einfach komplett absurde ideen die
schon bereits widerlegt sind für dieses
unglaublich viele beweise geben gibt
dass sie nicht stimmen also meine bitte
an euch wenn ihr youtube video sieht
guckt euch die von wirklich seriösen
kanälen an de abonniert bitte alles was
euch so einen quatsch erzählen will
es ist quatsch es sind lügen und es ist
einfach unwissen das verbreitet wird und
es gibt nichts schlimmeres
wir haben dafür ein bildungssystem es
gibt nichts schlimmeres als um bildung
bildung es waren sich wichtig lasst euch
also bilden seit intelligent werdet
schlaue durch bildung und lasst euch
nicht in die irre führen ja und das
beste mittel natürlich um schlau zu
werden schlau zu bleiben und andere
vielleicht auch noch zu machen ist
natürlich hier klickst der wissenschafts
kanal zumindest wird dieses themengebiet
dh wenn er immer die videos vorab zu
diesem thema zu vielen anderen themen
haben wollt dann abonniert mich hier
oder folgt mir hier auf whatsapp da
kriegt er
einen kontakt zu mir könnten wir dann
themen vorschlagen ihr könnt andere
vorschläge machen
es ist der direkte draht zu mir einfach
hier draufklicken und ansonsten verlinke
ich hier jetzt mal ein video wo ich mal
dampf abgelassen haben das mache ich
auch gerne wenn ich nicht unbedingt
klartext rede also bis dann bleibt dran